hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president trump heading to georgia to
rally for republicans
ahead of two key senate runoffs which
will determine which party controls the
senate
fox news sunday host chris wallace
discusses how the trump campaign's legal
challenges over the results of the
presidential election and attacks on
georgia election officials
could impact the outcome of the runoffs
and the direction of the country
several state and local leaders recently
coming under fire
for breaking the coronavirus
restrictions they've been enforcing
tony spell pastor of life tabernacle
church in louisiana
details why he believes places of
worship should be allowed to keep their
doors open
plus commentary from fox news
correspondent at large geraldo rivera
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm tyrus i'm liz clayman i'm greg
jarrett and this
is the fox news rundown
friday december 4th 2020 i'm chris
foster fox news sunday host chris
wallace
says president trump still has work to
do i think you're going to see him try
to do some things on policy whether it's
on china
whether it's on iran uh perhaps on
immigration
you know i think he's going to try to
lock in
his legacy to the degree that he
possibly can
i'm lisa brady he defies covet orders
and makes no apologies
now a controversial pastor is hoping the
supreme court
is on his side as gorsuch
and uh coney barrett has stated
the first amendment does not take a
sabbatical
the first amendment can't even take a
vacation and i'm geraldo rivera
i've got the final word on the fox news
run
we're now a month and a day since the
presidential election we used to have
what was called election day now we have
election days
weeks and months and lots of bad things
happened
during this ridiculous period of time
president trump's insisting that if you
only count legal votes he wins if we are
right about the fraud
joe biden can't be president we're
talking about
hundreds of thousands of votes the
courts to this point have not agreed but
that's not stopping the president from
making his case in that video from the
white house on social media and in voter
fraud hearings by supporters in states
won by president-elect biden if there
are people that thought the president
would leave the white house and spend
the rest of his term in mar-a-lago they
were wrong
they were indeed chris wallace is the
host of fox news sunday you know it's
interesting when the president
last week allowed the the government
services administration general services
administration the gsa
to begin the transition to allow people
from the biden team to come into the
various agencies and
find out what's going on people thought
well it's not the typical concession but
we seem to be
headed in that direction and then uh on
on wednesday we had this 46 minute
i guess like you kind of have to call it
a rant
by the president which he said was the
most important speech he's ever
delivered and i'm thinking to myself you
know
you've delivered speeches about sending
americans into war
uh about huge sacrifices and you for 46
minutes
give a speech with a lot of facts that
are just wrong
you know allegations statements that are
wrong they're not facts
uh about fraud in this election it
doesn't seem like he is
uh going quietly into that good night at
all
uh well and he's gonna be campaigning in
this george these two georgia senate
runoffs
tomorrow and we've got this interesting
situation where some of his supporters
are saying
oh no it's rigged don't vote so what was
this rally going to look like
well i'm sure the rally will be big
because
donald trump's there and people want to
go see him but i certainly agree with
you there's
tremendously mixed messages and it's got
a lot of republicans
uh in the senate but pulling their hair
out because
look they have to win both of these
elections
uh you know they only have to win one
now that i think of it they have to win
one of these elections
uh better to win both to hold on to the
senate if the democrats win both of them
it's 50 50
and kamala harris as the new vice
president would break the tie
so it's this is really important to win
these elections
and you've got the president attacking
the republican governor of georgia
attacking the republican
secretary of state of georgia and then
as you point out couple of
lawyers not formally on his team sydney
colin lynn
wood but they're they're saying don't
even come out and vote because
the election is fraudulent you know the
the election system
uh you know if you if you were going
about trying to depress the turnout
for your side you couldn't do a better
job of it than republicans are doing
right now
yeah the other day ronald mcdaniel the
republican national committee chairwoman
had
an event in georgia and was just taking
question after question why should i
bother to vote president trump says
my vote doesn't mean anything down here
exactly no and and
you know i don't know that they're going
to lose i think you'd still say the two
republicans
in in what is normally a red state even
though biden won it
uh are the favorites but if you know the
republicans could lose these are both
uh pretty close elections and if they do
and they lose control of the senate
they're gonna have to look it'll it
won't be the democrats will
beat them it'll have been some of their
fellow republicans yeah
assuming the electoral college in a week
and a half votes in joe biden president
trump will have 47 days left any
predictions for what he might try to get
done policy wise besides
you know we've heard a lot about people
he might pardon is there anything that
he
do you think he might want to get done
before he leaves oh i think he's going
to want to do as much as he can
and this this isn't totally unusual
although i think
as with most things he'll carry it more
to the extreme than
than most part departing presidents out
but i think they'll see a lot of pardons
um you know they're trying there's a
story in the new york times
that he's even talked about pardoning
his family
and rudy giuliani who haven't been
accused of any crimes particularly the
family uh
you know that's a hard one to say well
i'm gonna i'm gonna pardon
uh my my daughter and two sons
for crimes that nobody has accused them
of committing uh
that doesn't look or smells so good um
and and then i think you're gonna see
him try to do some things on policy
whether it's on china whether it's on
iran
uh perhaps on immigration you know i
think he's gonna
try to lock in his legacy to the degree
that he possibly can of course as we've
learned with executive orders
uh a lot of which obama did in his
second term
you know the president can issue an
executive order to do something and the
next president
can issue an executive order to undo
that and
you know he can he can try to lock
things in but to a large degree
if it's not a law and it isn't going to
be a law passed by the
congress because they're not they're
going to be lucky just to keep funding
the government
um you know it'll be something that
you'll see joe biden
undo uh on his first day in office well
president-elect biden has named some
more people joining him at the white
house any thoughts on his picks any
indication
of of of anybody who could be
problematic indications of where
he might be going with his agenda with
those people
yeah i think that you know uh
you're getting some squawking from the
right and from the left
and and you know the the right is saying
uh these people are too far to the left
and the left
is saying no they're not they're too too
far to the center
um i think it's a pretty mainstream look
he's a he's a liberal democrat he's not
a left-wing democrat
but he's a liberal democrat biden is and
i think but i think it's a pretty
moderate establishment liberal
uh a set of texts and almost all of them
look to me like they're gonna get
through easily people like anthony
blinken for secretary of state
janet yellen i think will sail through
his treasury secretary the one
who does seem to have around some higher
is near attention as the budget chief
and it isn't so much for things she's
done it's for things she said she uh
she has a way with twitter and she has a
way with emails and a lot of her emails
came out
uh during you know the the podesta
uh hack in 2016 where she was attacking
some fellow democrats and she also
between 2017 and 2020
took some shots at republican senators
is that enough to sink her i don't know
but but uh i i would say of all the
people so far
and you know i say so far we'll have to
wait and see his future picks
mira tandon is the one who seems to be
getting the roughest ride and you've had
some republican senators tom cotton
saying
he might as well just give up that
nomination there is no chance
i will say traditionally and it doesn't
mean that they always get blocked
but traditionally there is one or two
picks
of the new president and this was true
for donald trump back in 2017 with his
fix
that the opposition party tries to give
a tough time to
and and you know to take down to show
their that
their constituents you know we aren't
going to just roll over for this guy
i'd say at this point ira tandon looks
like she's in the uh
in the dunking chair for this one
yeah uh former president obama is
getting dragged a little from the left
for saying
this to fund the police movement is just
not helpful
and joe biden is going to be pulled this
way in that a little bit when he's in
office
oh absolutely uh and i think it's only
just begun uh you know you've heard
people
like uh alexandria ocasio-cortez
uh and other members of the so-called
squad say
you know we shut up during the election
because we wanted
to get donald trump out of there but now
that biden's in there we're not gonna
shut up anymore
um having said that uh the fact that so
many
uh people in the house lost that the
democrats did not have a good election
at all
with the exception of of joe biden
they're barely going to hold on to the
majority of the house
and unless they win these two seats in
georgia they're not going to get the
senate
um i'm not sure the left has a lot of a
lot of clout here i
i'm you know i'm not at all sure that
joe biden has to listen to them
all that much um and and you know what
obama was saying
was look if you wanna he said
you know as a community organizer and a
pretty successful politician he said
if you wanna say let's reform the police
and let's uh you know make sure criminal
justice works better
that's one thing but defund the police
he said you almost couldn't find a
slogan
that is going to antagonize more people
right off the bat so
you know if politics is about addition
not subtraction
not such a good way to go strikes me
that his logic is absolutely
unassailable but that doesn't mean
that you're going to not get some people
on the left who are going to uh
cry fouled on him we're coming up on 45
000
american coronavirus death just since
election day
in the last month and now a couple of
democrats are accused of not practicing
what they preach including this mayor
the mayor of austin texas steve adler
i don't know that it's going to change
anybody's mind what those people are
doing but it doesn't look good
no it's terrible looks terrible i mean
and you can and look who you've got
you've got the governor
of california newsom you have the mayor
of
uh of denver you have as you say the
mayor
of um austin texas you had a city
council woman in los angeles you know
all of them saying
don't go travel or don't go outdoor dine
and then doing
exactly that um and you know it just
makes it harder when you're saying play
by the rules look
we understand this is a pain in the neck
and we understand you're
tired of it but just hold on a little
bit longer until the vaccine comes
and then the people who are saying that
are not practicing what they preach
you know it makes it really hard um but
having said that
you know i don't think we can forget the
numbers are just horrendous
on on wednesday 200 000 new cases
new record uh a hundred thousand people
in the hospital for covid new record and
2 800
deaths new record even worse than april
now
the percentage of people who get it uh
is lower
who die rather is lower because we're
better at you know with these new
therapeutics
at treating them but when you get 200
000 new cases in a day
more people are going to die even if the
if the percentage of people who die
is lower so um you know we got
we can't give up on this even even if
some of the politicians who are telling
us what to do
are giving up on it well thanks chris uh
chris wallace host of fox news sunday
we'll talk to you soon
you bet thank you chris
this is geraldo rivera with your fox
news commentary
coming up the numbers tell the story
as the worldwide total of covet cases
tops
65 million with one and a half million
deaths it's now more than 14 million
cases in the u.s
and over 275 000 lives lost
the bottom line is if we don't act now
our hospital system
will be overwhelmed we don't act now
we'll continue to see a death rate
climb more lives lost california
governor gavin newsom issuing a
stay-at-home order that's tied to
hospitalizations
when icu bet availability falls below 15
percent
in a certain region the restrictions
would kick in for that area
which is expected to include most of the
state soon
newsom is one of the public officials
who've been criticized for not following
their own rules
and that list keeps growing we need to
you know stay home if you can do
everything you can to try to keep the
numbers down
this is not the time to relax the mayor
of austin texas steve adler
later admitting he made that video while
vacationing in cabo san lucas mexico
i'm sorry i took that trip it was a
lapse in judgment
apologizing in a follow-up video post
some business owners have been arrested
for intentionally violating rules they
say are unfair
or unfairly applied and constitutional
questions about state authority
persist on thursday the u.s supreme
court ordered a lower court to
re-examine california's restrictions on
indoor religious services a week after a
split decision
against attendance limits on churches
and synagogues in new york
although governor cuomo has called it a
moot point over limits that no longer
apply
but to many others it's significant the
five to four ruling
in favor of the catholic archdiocese
against cuomo
has been a tremendous victory for
religion in america
louisiana reverend tony spell is pastor
of life
tabernacle church in suburban baton
rouge where he stirred controversy
and arrest by continuing to hold large
services
even during the spring shutdown the
wording
that justice gorsuch has used
in limiting the power
of the jacobson 1905 case
has been tremendous for us which has
been the crux of the matter with these
egomaniacal scofflaw governors like
john bel edwards whose edicts
has charged me with nine crimes caused
me to be arrested
numerous times so what they're using is
this 1905
jacobson case where this swedish-born
pastor
who is in resident of massachusetts
refused to take a smallpox vaccine
the supreme court ruled against him
seven to two
and now these governors like cuomo and
john bel edwards have used that
to say that they can restrict our
in-person gatherings
well gorsuch said no that is irrelevant
so it's a tremendous win for religions
across
america i hear the argument a lot though
um you know why is a church restricted
when for instance a walmart
is not now a walmart does have more
space
than many churches so in some cases i
guess it's easy for people
easier to social distance in a big space
like that obviously in a mega church
like your space is not an issue but
in general why not say at least we can
hold services we're still allowed to
hold services
even if we have to limit the number of
people inside
well the answer to that is as
uh gorsuch and uh coney barrett has
stated
the first amendment does not take a
sabbatical
the first amendment can't even take a
vacation so
they are saying that we need equal
protection
as the retailers who by the way pay 51
of the revenue to the taxes in these
cities so
they said we have equal protection you
keep the liquor store the walmart's open
then the churches should be open we're
not even using that argument
we don't want equal protection we want
greater than protection we don't want
least restricted means
we don't want strict scrutiny because of
the first amendment congress shall make
no law restricting
an establishment of religion or
prohibiting the free exercise thereof
the answer is this is our religion
religion thomas jefferson said is man's
duty to god
not only is this our religion it is our
conviction
you know the bible says that i have
considered the words of god's mouth
more than my necessary food and that's
from the oldest book in the bible
so if they were to close everything down
in america
our church will just as it has the past
nine months
operate with no social distancing
zero masking we've had as many as 3 000
attendees in our services and that is
our duty to god
and no authoritarian governor can come
in and restrict that
although they've tried
i want to forgive me play devil's
advocate just for one more moment on
that point though
about the large gatherings and the no
masking i mean it it does make some
people
nervous such a big gathering and
especially just as the pandemic was
reaching its first peak in the u.s
um in the spring i mean
what do you say about the argument that
okay you've got a constitutional right
to
freedom of religion however you don't
have a right to
jeopardize the health of other people
it's a tremendous point that you're
making if the virus was so
deadly and it was not politically
motivated
then why not close everything down
that's where equal protection comes in
so we knew that this was politically
motivated
on march the 15th when we held sole
ownership of in-person church services
in america and that's when i they came
in and arrested me
in my prayer meeting the chief of police
and assistant chief of police so we're
arguing that it can't be so deadly
if you're going to the store to the mall
to planned parenthood all of these
retailers
remained open however he restricted the
churches he said
zero attendees in a building
so you see the double standard diver's
weights and false balances
judge james c ho answered your question
in the fifth circuit court of appeals
he was the only judge that ruled in my
favor
they had a two to one against us he said
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander governor edwards how dare you
praise
the protesters for practicing the first
amendment rights
but prosecute the pastor for practicing
this first amendment right
so you see if it was
you got you have to use the argument if
i'm endangering people's lives with no
mask and no social distancing
then why are the protesters allowed to
burn
luton and riot and why are
the stores allowed to remain open now
that's the equal protection argument of
course
our lawsuit is not like the catholic
archdiocese
our lawsuit is on greater protection
first amendment of no laws can be made
so
we never forced anyone to come to church
those hundreds and
even thousands of people that come to
our church three times
weekly they know the risk that they're
taking
what have you noticed reverend about
faith
during the pandemic i know you're saying
you've had an influx of people
but in general do you feel like more
people
are turning to churches and other houses
of worship
wanting to pray or are they drifting
away or is it about
evenly split from what you've seen
there's a great revival
of people coming to the house of god
as we see you know i have not had
a coveted funeral in my church but i
have preached many
suicide funerals of young girls
murder victims of young teenage boys who
are out of school
on the streets little girls who have
out of school now unable to graduate
their futures have been taken from them
who have taken their lives so with the
hurt and the hopelessness and the
helplessness in our society
people are turning to god at a greater
ratio
than ever before so if you were to
search
the word of god 66 bible books 1189
chapters 31
102 verses in the king james version
bible
the cursory study is the more they
afflict us the more we multiply and grow
and what evil means for bad
god means for good so people are turning
two
now the other side of the coin is is
that people have lost
faith in religion in their pastors their
priests
their leaders for example a catholic
evangelist has converted to my faith in
my church and i've ordained
him into our ministry because the first
thing the catholic church did
during the beginning of the virus
pandemic was pour out the holy water
and banned them from taking sacrament
well he was so angered at that that he
was
looking for his spiritual help
and he happened to see me uh get booked
into the east baton rouge parish prison
and his heart was overwhelmed and the
rest is history he's since now for about
six months
been a part of our faith so i see an
influx of people coming towards god
because of this politics have failed him
education has failed them
they've lost their retirements
what hope and help do they have but to
turn to god
in this time of peril reverend i just
want to give you a chance to
address people who accuse you of being
just out for attention
just out for publicity what do you say
to that
i would say to that if i'm doing this
for publicity and attention
then tell that to the people who i allow
to use my building with more than nine
people in their loved one's funeral
attendance
tell that to the hundreds of thousands
of dollars that i've given
to people in the past nine months
who can't keep their lights on who can't
put food on their table
tell that to the person that i gave one
of my vehicles away to
in the past nine months just so they
could keep their head above water after
theirs was repossessed
i've added five buses to my bus fleet in
the past
nine months so that we could go out and
bring more people into the house of god
right now we're responsible for 11
full-time ministries
feeding them financially
helping them so this isn't about
attention
if it was about attention then
i would have stopped whenever i came out
of the east baton rouge parish prison
because that's not good attention that's
notorious attention that's infamous
attention
it never has been about attention this
is about our obligation and duty to god
reverend tony spell thank you very much
for spending so much time with us and
stay safe thank you
and god bless you in america
it's the perino and stir walt i'll tell
you what podcast
dana perino of the five and fox news
political editor chris stirwald
dissect the ins and outs of national
politics subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
the film called dear santa shows how the
u.s postal service's
operations santa program works each year
operation santa feels hundreds of
thousands of letters
santa's helpers sort the request
volunteers help sponsor
them letters are online today to browse
and adopt
kids who want to send a letter can do
that too the address is 123
elf road north pole 88888
post market by december 14th don't
forget the return address and stamp
to see the documentary go to
dearsanta.movie
to adopt a letter go to
uspsoperationsanta.com
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
geraldo rivera
what's on your mind president trump has
been hounded from the moment he was
first elected in 2016.
democrats have sought to construe in the
most evil way possible
trump's every word or deed for almost
three years he was harassed in an
exercise
in character assassination otherwise
known as russia russia russia
that long national nightmare was based
on nothing
but the unverified deep state ramblings
of a trump-hating
retired secret agent funded by democrats
remember how this insane year 2020
started
we were preoccupied with the president's
impeachment
remember impeachment which really turned
out to be like another episode of the
old seinfeld show
also about nothing despite attempts by
some sore
loser democrats to destroy trump's
presidency
he hung in there getting unprecedented
judicial vacancies filled
including three supreme court justices
he steered an economy
that brought a measure of prosperity to
the poorest among us
minority unemployment at record lows
international trade deals getting done
along with peace deals
isis finished and the war in syria
then came the plague that ravaged so
many millions of lives
becoming for lots of reasons the one
issue the president could not shake off
or may go away it cost him his closely
contested bid for reelection
i understand how frustrated he must feel
but to those who have known him longest
it feels as if he is finally reaching
the stage of grief
and acceptance at the bitter end of this
bizarre year
it was crazy close if only 40 000 votes
in three states had gone the other way
the mainstream media would still be
searching for real or imagined reasons
to hate him he will survive and maybe
we'll still have trump to kick around
in 2024 i'm geraldo rivera reporting
fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say
alexa play news from fox in fox news
it's the latest when you need it on
demand
from fox news and amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes